award-winning author jason reynolds is
inspiring the next generation to read
and to write he has written more than a
dozen books for young adults
many of which are published by simon
schuster which by now you know is a
division of icom cbs
earlier this year we revealed reynolds
was named the new national ambassador
for young people's literature for the
library of congress
next month he's going to start a virtual
tour to meet with students across the
country
and right now jason joined hello jason
reynolds from washington d.c
good to see you listen to see you gail
yeah when this was first announced i
know you had great plans i know how you
love to go out and meet the kids and
talk to them face to face nobody thought
all these months later we would still be
still be dealing with covid but here we
are so what's your strategy as you start
this tour with connecting with the kids
virtually
what you're going to do we have to pivot
you know at the end of the day i
i you know honestly gail i think um
ultimately
if if virtual is the way that we have to
do it then that's the way we have to do
it but
but not doing it at all is not an option
so what are you going to do
to connect with them so we're going to
do a
virtual tour we're going to still do it
as if we were traveling so the same
kinds of places the same small towns i'm
doing like beckley west virginia swansea
south carolina rantoul
illinois right these smaller towns and
we're going to all get on
our digital platforms and we're still
going to run the campaign and the
platform the way that we had originally
planned right an open interview
lots of discourse giving the kids an
opportunity to tell me about their towns
and what they're proud about
and really create a human moment even
through
a digital sphere yeah jason jason
anthony when you
i know when you when you meet with kids
usually you have a particular way you
try to dress
to create a connection there i want you
to talk about that but i also want to
talk about talking about the connection
now and make kids
want to learn because it's so hard right
now i mean as i've often talked my
wife's a teacher
getting them engaged and excited it's
such a hard moment
yeah it really is a difficult moment i
mean in terms of dress you know i always
like to show up
t-shirt jeans and sneakers i'm a casual
kind of guy
um i i i like to refl i like for them to
look at me and see themselves which i
think is a very
a very important thing um but in terms
of how do we engage them in this moment
look ultimately i think that there is a
bit of screen fatigue
and i think it is going to require us to
get a little more creative
um i think games work uh i think also i
think we have to kind of push ourselves
a bit because just talking to the
monitor
isn't going to be enough i also think we
have to make sure we allow them to turn
their mics on
and let them do some talking and i think
that is another way to sort of keep them
locked in
you know your book stamped racism
anti-racism and you
debuted it number one go you on the new
york times young adult
hardcover list and then it rose to the
top again in june
but i've heard you say that you have
mixed emotions about this what do you
mean
it's complicated gail i am
ultimately grateful that that book is
doing whatever it is doing
i think that it is a wonderful tool for
young people especially
to help them build vocabulary lexicon
and armor
as it pertains to the conversation
around race for that i feel wonderful
about
what's complicated is
trying my best to make sure that i stay
focused and that i recognize that it's
easy to slip
into strange profiteering spaces when it
comes to
these kinds of books becoming successful
at opportune times
and then the other thing is and the
other thing is making sure that i don't
even
buy into the idea that this book can can
fix
the problem and what happens is all
these adults have brought the book and
i'm grateful
i'm grateful yeah but uh but i but i
don't want people to think that this
book is the
is the only answer or is the answer to
the to the problem of racism in america
jason you've
you've said it it's probably the most
important thing i'll ever make
but that you're also concerned that that
anti-racism
will become kind of what you call i
think a vanilla word what did you mean
you know i i think that what dr kindy
did
with his research um with all the work
that he did
is something that we should all be
praising i think what happens though
when it comes to
the digital zeitgeist and and the sort
of
the the way that technology speeds
everything up and makes everything
uh sort of everything becomes a
household name so quickly
is that i think that some of the some of
the some of the zip gets taken out of
some of the things right i remember the
word woke when woke was a thing
right and and it you know and it was
like yeah everybody's like i'm woke i'm
woke and woke and then all of a sudden
you realize it meant nothing anymore
problematic is another one of those
words right
we have a way of killing language and
and stripping language of the meaning
that and
and the and the weight that sometimes
the words supposed to hold so
true becomes like a brand name almost as
you say jason you're so good
yeah every time you come you leave us
with something we're all
nodding away over here well good luck
with the kids out there jason it's going
to i'd
be really curious to see how they
respond oh man i'm looking forward to it
it's going to be a light to my life
that's for sure yeah
yeah all right jason reynolds thank you
so much for being with us this morning
it's always a pleasure
we will be right back stay with us